what is a Grosvenor basis if that is
your intent from what this Q&A episode
is going to be as far as technicality
and deep explanation is concerned you're
gonna be grossly disappointed same goes
to whoever asked about what the Fourier
transform has to do with quantum
computing I can say at a high level it's
because the Fourier transform gives you
a unitary operation and quantum
computing is very fast when it comes to
anything that can be expressed as a
unitary matrix but those words won't
make sense if you don't already know
what it means and this is not at all
meant to be a video that's going to go
into some deep math explanation but when
I do cover quantum computing which I
will at some point what would you do
professionally if it weren't for youtube
/ what are you doing professionally so a
lot of you might know I used to work for
Khan Academy and I think if I wasn't
doing this I would definitely seek out
some other way of doing math outreach
online intent of the question is maybe
more what would I do that has nothing to
do with math outreach I spent a lot of
time doing like random software
engineering things through college like
my summer internships were often spent
at a tech company rather than doing
something explicitly math related but if
I really you know turn on that parallel
universe machine I think going into data
science was a very real possibility you
know one of the internships that I was
doing at the end of it they asked if I
wanted to instead of going to college
again just stick around and maybe have a
full-time job and just see what unfolded
there and I seriously considered it you
know it's pretty compelling ultimately
the love for pure math one-ounce wife
did go back to school as you're supposed
to but I kind of do wonder what would
have been if instead I went that
professional data science about how
arbitrary do you think our mathematical
perspective is as humans on earth if an
alien civilization developed math from
scratch do you think we would see
clearer similarities and their
development of the fields like number
theory trigonometry and calculus so this
is an interesting question because it
cuts right to the heart of his math
invented or discovered and I like the
phrasing where you kind of imagine an
alien civilization coming and comparing
your math to theirs it's hard to
speculate on this right like I have no
idea some aliens came we have no way of
knowing whether their math would look
completely different from ours one thing
you can be pretty sure of and this might
seem superficial is
that the notation would be entirely
different right there's a lot of
arbitrary choices and how we write
things down Newton's notation for
calculus versus liveness notation for
calculus you know a lot of the really
silly things we have like which side of
the variable the function goes on
writing out the letters si in for sine
cosine I had the whole triangle of power
video about you know notations for
radicals and Exponential's and on the
one hand that might not feel substantive
but I think it's really interesting to
contemplate other ways where the
notation shapes the way that we think
about it and shapes the axioms and
theorems we even choose more so than we
give it credit for so a project I'm
actively working on right now is about
quaternions
and I was a little bit surprised to
learn how up in the air the potential
notations and conventions for teaching
students about vectors was like a lot of
the actual notation and terminology we
have for vectors and cross products dot
products the way we think of them in 3d
ultimately stems from quaternions you
know even the fact that we use IJ and K
as letters to represent the XY and z
directions and if Hamilton had had his
way we would still teach engineering
students primarily about quaternions and
then things like the dot product and
cross product would be viewed as subsets
of what the quarter neons do and what
cuatro neon multiplication is and I
think there's a compelling case to be
made for the fact that we would use that
if we could visualize four dimensions
better but the reason that quaternions
never really won out as the notation de
jure is because they're confusing cuz no
one really understood them there's all
sorts of hilarious quotes from Lord
Kelvin and alike about how quaternions
are just needlessly confiding when
you're trying to phrase some fact about
the universe like Maxwell's equations
were originally written much more
quaternion eclis than we teach them to
students now and arguably they're much
more elegant that way but it's confusing
because we can't visualize it so I think
if you had some alien civilization that
came but they had a very good spatial
conception for four dimensions they
would look at our vector notation and
think that it was not capturing the
deeper realities of math arguably who
knows what do you think is the main
thing that drives people away from math
always hard to answer on these kind of
things but I really suspect that as soon
as you wrap something at a certain kind
of judgment of there's a notion of being
correct or in Korea
or an implicit statement there's a
notion of being good at math some people
are math people some people aren't math
people as soon as you get someone
identifying that they're not a math
person first you know insinuating that
that even makes sense and then
insinuating that they fall into that
like of course you're not gonna like it
of course your natural mind turnings
aren't going to go in the direction of
some puzzle because you'd much rather to
think about things that you're good at
and that make you feel happy all of the
latest stuff about growth mindsets and
Carol Dweck and Joe bowler really behind
that you know the idea that if you're
trying to tell a student something about
how they're doing with math rather than
framing it around oh you must be so
smart right in framing around oh you
must have worked very hard you must have
put a lot of a lot of time into that
there's a lot of much less judgmental
things that we have out there like
reading even though there's some notions
of reading comprehension tests for
students in school and you know you're
reading at an eighth grade level people
usually aren't like oh I'm not a reading
person right like I those words like
some people that just make sense to them
but for me those letters I don't know
how they come together when it comes to
contest map like the AMC I think those
can be really good for high schoolers as
a bank of problems I think they can be
really bad for high schoolers as an
insinuation of there's some like top
tier math folk and they can do these
problems really quickly but if you give
the same questions to a student and you
say rather than being forced to go
through all of these in 75 minutes you
say let's let's spend 30 minutes on just
one of them by really doughy
to it they're really solid problems that
kind of engage in the spirit of problem
solving and you know removing that
judgemental aspect removing that time
aspect I think you know I can help out a
lot lot of people ask about certain
things that I've made promises for but
haven't necessarily delivered on in a
recent video you know I did one on
divergence and curl and I mentioned at
the end an example of using complex
numbers to model fluid flow and a
certain model for flow around a wing and
you might notice I have yet to actually
put out a video on that and I've
certainly seen a number of commenters
you know hampering on me for that fact
if there's ever a thing that I promise
them that I don't make a video on it
it's probably because I spent a good
amount of time trying to write a script
for it that I just didn't feel was
compelling for whatever reason and I
think maybe the granddaddy here is the
probability series which at the moment I
have five videos that I've made that are
you know released to patrons I don't I
just don't feel great about them and I
kind of want the stuff that I put out to
you guys to be something I feel is you
know if not original something that
wouldn't be out there otherwise from
other creators and there's a lot of good
probability material online I will
probably do something to release the
material that I have either just as it
is but on some second channel with the
acknowledgement hey this isn't the
greatest work I think I've done or
trying to rework them and make them
stand Alone's but as far as you know
essence of blank content I feel much
clearer about how I would want to extend
the linear algebra series rather than
spinning my wheels on certain scripts
and animations that I ultimately don't
think are gonna deliver something to you
guys that I would feel proud of do you
have any questions - Brill I'm just
reading from reading from some reddit
ones here but we do something live how
much compromise if any do you have to
give with like what you can animate
versus like what your script is trying
to convey usually if I can't animate a
thing and it's a mathematical thing it's
not like a frivolous cartoonish type
thing I change the tools so that it can
animate that thing right and then that
might take more time and it's possible
that subconsciously that means I resist
topics that I know would be more
difficult to animate I don't think that
happens I like to use that to encourage
creation of new things right like on the
divergence curl didn't have good fluid
flow stuff but it was fun to play around
with that for quaternions right now I
think there's a lot of 3d related things
that I wanted to sort of upgrade because
the previous way I was doing a lot of 3d
animations was clunky and not as
extensible as I wanted it to be so
usually use that as a good excuse to
just improve the graphics tool
we have somewhere a question on here
what sort of music do you listen to
which I mostly wanted to answer to like
mention my renewed love for the Punch
Brothers I don't know if any of you know
about them they're actually super weird
they're like a avant-garde bluegrass
band it's just five geniuses who get
together and put out phenomenal art so
can't complain about that how do you
compare making your videos to making
videos for Khan Academy so very
different processes right like Khan
Academy you imagine sitting next to
someone and tutoring them and just
explaining it you're writing everything
by hand for the most part you do it live
on this channel I obviously script
things I put a lot of time into creating
the visuals for it sometimes in a way
that makes me feel you know if it kind
of Quetta me I could sit down and make
like three videos in an afternoon and
here it's taking me like three weeks to
do one video you know which of these
actually carries more of an impact I
think there's a proper balance for both
of them and I think there's a lot of
people out there who do the Const Isle
stuff to include Khan Academy but also
many others the way I like to think
about things is what wouldn't happen if
I wasn't doing it but there is that
little part of me that thinks maybe I
should start some sort of second channel
of the super cheap just like me and a
notebook and a pencil like scrapping
through some sort of explanation super
quickly
who makes the awesome music playing in
your videos
Vince Rubin Eddy link in the description
link in all of the descriptions actually
he does really good work and just go you
know download some of the music and
leave him a little tip if you feel like
it's something that you enjoy what is
your favorite Paloma No
Paloma no Polly mongrel this one I'll
figure it out later and insert it on the
screen alright folks thanks for watching
stick around for whenever the next
upload is it's going to be on
quaternions and I hope you like it
this is your close-up this is your wife
all right
does that probably mean I should be
looking at the wide one or do I do a
dramatic like camera number two